University of Maryland charges each
student undergraduate $400 a year to
subsidize the football program even
though the football program brings in
television revenue gate receipts and so
on and they do it because they can get
away with it hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
reason TV and today we're talking with
Greg Easterbrook he is the author most
recently of the king of sports footballs
impact on America Greg thanks for
joining us glad to be here this is a
book that is both critical but also you
know very praising of football and its
general impact and influence on American
culture we'll get to the positives in a
minute but what I want to talk about
first is about how taxpayers support
college and pro football whether or not
they ever buy a ticket or go to a game
you write the twenty nine million
dollars Rutgers tuition subsidy for
athletics worked out to nearly $1,000
per student in-state tuition that year
Rutgers is a public university was
twelve thousand seven hundred and fifty
four dollars meaning that eight percent
of tuition charges paid by parents
actually were charges for the four NCAA
athletics and now talk a bit about that
how does this happen
because everybody is bitching and
moaning about college prices going up
and yet as you documented here and it's
not just Rutgers even powerhouses like
Florida they are sucking money out of
the general fund for a collar college or
university to go to it how does this
happen a lot of what's wrong with the
way the financial structure of American
life this happens because people can get
away with it and schools do this because
we can they can get away with it we're
doing this interview about 10 miles from
College Park where University of
Maryland has a power house football
program University of Maryland charges
each student undergraduate four hundred
dollars a year to subsidize the football
program even though the football program
brings in television revenue gate
receipts and so on and they do it
because they can get away with it I
think parents who pay most college bills
largely don't know this is happening the
four hundred dollars is buried in
mysterious asterisks on your tuition
bill but there were only half a dozen
big college programs in the whole
country that are not actively subsidized
by the universities even though they're
they're clearing thirty to forty million
dollars a year in profit after paying
all salaries and expenses do you think
this is a question of if parents act if
this was publicized more because you
hear a lot
a kind of general bromide of people
saying well you know at these big
schools at least the football and
basketball procurements make money and
they subsidize you know English or the
fine arts when in fact as you were
saying that's just not true is it a
question of people understanding this
and then pushing back against it yeah
and it's not true you mentioned the
University of Florida which is a nice
public university and also a good
athletic school University of Florida
the football program draws 1 to 5
million dollars a year in direct
subsidies from the academic mission of
the school they're basically what
they're doing is that they're leasing
the University of Florida's traditions
their colors and their tax exemptions to
run a very small not-for-profit business
that pays its executives quite well and
as you point out I mean generally
particularly at the bigger football
factories I mean there's a couple of
exceptions but generally not only that
but the football players actually
graduate at much lower rates in the
student well that's a separate issue but
that's my big my big concern I'll finish
up the last one just by saying there are
only half a dozen programs in Division
one despite the huge increase in revenue
that actually pay their own way Ohio
State does University Oklahoma
University of Texas a few do but most do
not most are actively harming the
academic finances of their institutions
now should-should college football
players be paid some people think so I
don't think so we could talk about that
I think the big scandal of college
football is that 55 percent of Division
1 players graduate that's an outrage the
the the value of a college diploma is
greater economically it's about a
million dollars to your lifetime
earnings it's greater than the players
could be paid under any possible scheme
what percentage of college scholarship
players go on to play in the NFL it's 1
1 % or something 1 in 30 ever receive an
NFL paycheck because of scholarship
players and one in a hundred stay in the
NFL long enough to have anything
resembling a career so if they're all
going on to huge bonus checks this
wouldn't matter but they're not going on
to huge bonus checks as I say in King of
sports are being used up and thrown away
now let's talk about how this plays out
in the in NFL which again is a league
that is almost all of the owners are if
not hundred millionaires they're
billionaires
and yet you write that 87% of stadia
capital financing comes out of taxpayers
dollars how is this happening well again
I think it's just because owners are
able to bully legislators and get away
with it if you were the City Council's
or state legislators tend to make these
decisions and funding an NFL stadium say
that half a billion dollars in Minnesota
just gave to fund a new stadium for the
Minnesota Vikings enables you to make a
dramatic announcement there'll be
thousands of new jobs and huge economic
activity and tourism and you know you're
gonna be retired before the bills for
those bonds come to do anyway on the
other hand if you went to the mat with
an NFL owner and he did move his team I
don't think this is likely but suppose
it happened you would be blamed and you
would immediately be voted out of office
is there any reason to believe when when
either politicians or boosters or team
owners say look if we put a stadium in
here it's really going to jack up the
local economy is that true
I wish it were - studies show that the
stadium spending does have a little bit
of effect on the local economy but
nothing proportionate to the cost it has
a very little multiplier effect if
you're building roads or bridges those
things have economic multiplier effects
spending on stadiums really only
produces economic activity ten days of
the year and the NFL it's just not
enough to be noticeable the ownership
structure of the NFL you know their arch
capitalists in one way but another way
they're also socialist because the
revenue sharing has allowed for parody
in the league which creates better
competition yeah I think I think revenue
sharing is a great idea in the NFL one
reason the games are consistently good
as the Jacksonville Jaguars have just as
much money to work with us Adela's
Cowboys so it results in good
competition that Jacksonville is not
good this particular year but overall it
means good competition so this is one of
the ways in which football I think sinks
American culture everybody in football
talks rock-ribbed conservatism
self-reliance and their economic
structure is subsidies and guaranteed
benefits isn't that America we all want
to talk about we're rock-ribbed
self-reliant and where is my benefits I
mean football is structured that way and
as a final note as long as we're talking
about the NFL ownership structure talk a
bit about the nonprofit status how that
plays into this
all kind of ability to on the one hand
talk about being self-reliant and on
another hand get as much out of the
public tail as possible by act of
Congress 1966 and I fell headquarters
not the individual teams but NFL
headquarters as chartered as a
not-for-profit they don't pay any
federal or state X actually income taxes
and Roger Goodell the Commissioner paid
himself thirty million dollars in the
most recent year on paper he appears to
be running at public spirited charity
and paying himself thirty million
dollars a year as an outrage can you
quote the the actual tax law that was
amended to include and the NFL it was a
classic example of the lobbyists are at
1966 when a piece of legislation full of
little sweeteners for the NFL was
passing a lobbyist got the words and
professional football league's slipped
into the legal definition of a
not-for-profit so that great that that
great humanitarian that philanthropic
benefactor Roger Goodell now runs a
not-for-profit a final question there's
been a lot of talk recently about how
football because of brain injuries
concussions at all levels but then it
leads to you know finally at the pier at
the top of the pyramid you have people
like jr. say oh and other great players
have committed suicide and then people
are starting to say well it's because
their brains have been banged up by
playing football do you think football
does this pose a serious risk to the
long-term future of football are people
going to say look this is a blood sport
and we've got to get rid of it oh I
think it's a huge risk to football no
it's not the only dangerous sport the
rates of concussion per hour of playing
soccer and football are relatively
similar but because so many more people
are involved in playing football if
you're asking what sport does the most
health damage it's got to be football
and in unless the sport is made more
safe I think it is a long-term threat to
the game yes we will leave it there the
book is the king of sports footballs
impact on America the author is Greg
Easterbrook thanks for talking about the
reason TV for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie